hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar deep multiomic phenotyping
of biospecimens for immuno-oncology
applications
i am michelle ashton of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by miltoni biotech to
learn more
visit www.nopabiotech.com
let's get started before we give i would
like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker dr sean
saul the director of flow cytometry
services
at discovery life sciences for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biology tab at the top
of your screen
dr fall you may now begin your
presentation welcome
thank you michelle and and thank you
everybody for joining us today
um today i'm going to talk about our
multi-analytical platforms
for uh phenotyping and characterizing
our human biospecimens for downstream io
applications
for those of you unfamiliar with
discovery life sciences
discovery life sciences is built on four
key competencies
um the first and the base of these key
competencies is biospecimens both the
acquisition
preparation and preservation of these
samples these samples come in multiple
different formats including fixed
samples such as ffpe
viable samples such as pbmc's bone
marrow mononuclear cells and associated
tumor cells which we'll talk about a
little bit later in the presentation
um we do have full emr access into all
of our clinical sites
um so these samples come with a high
degree of annotation
we also have a normal donor clinic
through this normal donor clinic we have
access
to biofluids from normal donors
including apheresis products
which is something else we'll discuss
today off of this base of biospecimens
we have
three analytical pipelines
for which we can help to annotate these
downstream
specimens the first is genomics in this
case we offer a full suite of whole
genome whole exome and rna-seq
technologies
these also include targeted sequencing
as well as long-range sequencing
platforms
additionally we have iec capabilities
this is both in terms of the validation
and testing of clinical samples at scale
on again multiple different platforms
as well as in-house pathologists um to
to analyze and interpret that data
finally um we have a self-services
platform this platform deals with
all assays in which are viable cells for
starting materials so this is primarily
flow cytometry
although we do also offer cell culture
cell isolations as well as 10x genomics
technologies
downstream of these products for today's
webinar
um we're going to focus on three main
learning points
the first point is how we phenotype our
apheresis donors and how we use this
information for both determining
uh potential donors for downstream cell
therapy manufacturing
as well as for different cell isolations
on the last two learning points we'll
focus on our dissociated tumor cell
offering
on the second one we'll focus on how we
use
flow cytometry to characterize these
samples as well as use them for
identifying samples for different
downstream platforms
and then finally the third learning
point will focus on our use of single
cell genomic technologies
to use for identifying novel biomarkers
again in dissociated tumor cells
our apheresis clinic is located directly
adjacent to
our production facility which allows
seamless transition
from the apheresis donor to downstream
manufacturing we currently have five
chairs in operation although by the end
of the year that will be up to eight
chairs
we're currently using the spectra optia
as our apheresis machine
with acda as our anticoagulant all of
our donors
are hla-typed by next-gen sequencing for
six digit high resolution
and all of our donors go through viral
screening for hep b
hep c and hiv as well as cmv and ebv
reactivity
our cell viability is consistently about
95 percent or greater
um directly after collection we do use a
do nucleation dye cell counter in this
case the next one silometer for cell
counting
and we are iso 9001 certified
we do offer this aphrosis material in
several formats
um both fresh and frozen leukopaks um in
either a full half or quarter size
we then further isolate these leukopaks
down to mononuclear cells
again offered in multiple sizes or any
of the
major immune cell populations present in
peripheral blood
additionally we do do culture um to
generate both macrophages and dendritic
cells from monocytes harvested from our
aphorisis donors
and we will soon be releasing gmb
compliant lego packs on for more
information
on that offering please feel free to
contact us at info.info
dls.com so our africa's donors are
fully typed at the hla loci um this
slide just gives you
an indication of the number of unique
alleles we see at each locus
to show that we do have a breadth of
many many different alleles that
are available we more commonly ask for
hla-0203 and a24
we do have over 100 donors in each of
those
hla types and these can be offered
usually we have donors that are
uh ao2 and then a03 or another allele
but we do have some donors
represent on both ao2 on both alleles
additionally we did validate an in-house
flow cytometry assay to also look at ao2
reactive donors or ao2 positive donors
this assay allows us to
evaluate donors real time and gives us a
binary yes no as to if these donors are
too positive or negative and those are
the flow plots shown in the bottom right
additionally the donors are classified
for reactivity against cmb and ebv
this is done by eliza um consistent with
with other reports about half of our
donor population is reactive to cmv
while um the majority are reactive to
ebv
um this data becomes very useful with
the hla data because we can now classify
donors and look for antigen-specific t
cells which is displayed in the right
panels here these are looking at donors
that were classified as
dnd reactive or non-reactive by serology
elisa
um then using dextromers against the
specific peptide from cmv we can
identify cdat cells
from hlao to positive donors um that
were previously classified as cmv
reactive or non-reactive so this allows
us to use this data
to further hone in on donors that would
be suitable for uh downstream assays um
that we're trying to run
the real power of what we're doing with
our aphorism clinic though is our
immunophenotyping of all our donors that
come through the clinic so
in in this schematic shows how that
workflow um is performed in this case
the donor leukopak is
brought into the lab and inflated down
into the mononuclear cell fraction
um at this point we use miltani
miltoni's max quant 16 flow cytometer
we have um analysis templates that we've
set up that
the technicians can seamlessly stain the
cells
and stain for either lymphocyte or
monocyte populations
within each donor and that for therefore
they'll
have the ability to know which donors
would be good either for shipping fresh
or frozen leukopaks that are required to
have a specific percentage of each cell
population
or for downstream isolation on an
eventual choir
preservation in-house
so looking at our donor population um as
box box and whisker plots here um you
can see there is a lot of variability
within the donor pool
on for each cell type that we're
currently profiling
what we've done is use this data to
basically set thresholds um and these
thresholds um which are displayed in
these orange boxes
allow us to define which donors would or
would not be good for downstream
isolations and so this allows us to get
the most efficiency out of a leukopak um
it ensures the highest purity
of these cells downstream such that if
we do a t
cell donor who fall below 50 we're
fairly confident that our our efficiency
and our purity will be very low and we
try to avoid
having any inefficiencies with these
packs
just to make them the most out of all
this material that we do receive into
the lab
in addition to immunophenotyping these
donors we also perform functional assays
in-house
an example for of that is a large t-cell
expansion project
that we recently completed um in this
case the apheresis donors were brought
in
and the entire leukopak was isolated
onto cd3t cells um at this point a
proportion of the pack
was frozen down as as primary
non-expanded cells
um a very small proportion of that total
population was then expanded
using the milk penny transact system
over
about 14 to 20 days this gives us an
expanded t-cell population
um to provide which best represents
an expanded population used for car
t-cell therapies
additionally during this expansion
process we evaluated not only the cell
counts and the rough cell size during
the expansion
but also on the expression of known
regulators of t cell function or that
are kinetically
different throughout the expansion
process and in this case that cd25 cd69
and pd1 were the key markers we were
looking at
um using this we can follow the t cell
activation throughout the entire study
this allows us to know when was the best
time to remove the stimulus um to allow
the cells rest
prior to preservation and also get the
platform for additional
um target molecules to be analyzed
throughout this entire
uh time course so in this way we really
use the the max cloud platform not only
to phenotype the initial patient samples
to identify which donors are best for
which projects but then also for
downstream
um expansion and functionality tests
for the remainder of the talk i'm going
to focus on our dissociative tumor cell
offering
and first we're going to talk about how
we've really hyper annotated
these associated tumor cells at a very
large scale
um so dissociative tumor cells are
single cell suspensions
of solid tumor indications we have also
performed
dissociations of normal tissue some
autoimmune tissue
and some metastatic tissue most of that
metastatic tissue is melanoma lymph
nodes
um this is generated via proprietary
mechanical engineering digestion
these cells are then preserved and this
really allows us to have full annotation
of the sample
prior to using it for any study while
the pathologists
are very very good at identifying what
the tumor is upon resection
um every once in a while we do find an
instance where upon review a colorectal
cancer
actually turned out to be some sort of
non-hodgkin's lymphoma
um and so that obviously is problematic
if colorectal cancer
is what you're looking for so we let
these cells
cryopreserve on the crop reserve is very
good in terms of maintaining viability
um after the thaw it's still 70 or
greater
um and then that allows for the best
annotation and selection of samples for
downstream platforms
so what we do for all of these
associated tissues is after they go
through the freeze-thaw
cycle upon thaw they go through a flow
cytometry
analysis to classify all of the cellular
subsets
in the tumor as well as hlao2 status by
flow
again a binary is the donor hla o2
positive or negative
the panel that we're currently running
is 12 markers
large um we first pre-gate out
all dead cells and that's one thing that
we found to be incredibly crucial with
these dissociative tissues
is that the use of a live dead
discriminator be that a um
a dna die such as dappy or pi or any of
the immune reactive fixable live dead
discriminators
is really crucial as these associated
tissues of a fair amount of
debris that can complicate downstream
flow analysis
we also recommend the use of a marker
against red cells we do use cd2
235 a or gly a um in this manner um for
fresh dissociation there are a lot of
red cells present and these do remain
after cryo preservation
um the initial flow plots that we look
at um are
plots of cd45 versus fcam um this allows
us to identify cd45 positive immune
cells
um which you can see in the bottom right
corner of the flow plot versus
epcam positive tumor cells in the top
left
we do use fcam for all of our tumors
with a couple exceptions
melanoma does not express fcam we
validated a couple different markers and
found cd146
um to be the best marker for identifying
melanoma tumor cells
so for melanoma we do use cd146 um
for glioblastoma and hepatocellular
carcinoma um we have yet have yet not
identified a marker
that reliably works for us um so when i
show some data later um just keep in
mind that those two subsets are going to
under represent
on the tumor cell fraction just because
we don't have a great marker for
identifying that
um following this gating strategy we
further classify
all of the immune cell populations by
the major
lymphoid and myeloid populations that
would be present within the tumor
um this includes the cd4 and cd8 t cells
as well as the b cell populations
uh we do look at nk cells they tend to
be the rarest of all the cell types that
we are
analyzing so we will gate on cd3
negative cells prior to analyzing those
um and then we do look at myeloid cells
both as cd11b positive
and then on the monocytic or
granulocytic cells by the expression of
cd14 or cd15 respectively
at this point we have analyzed over 2500
unique primary tumor samples um this is
a heat map
showing the average of each of the cell
types that we do characterize
across about almost 20 different
indications um and we're going to go
through the heat map a little bit more
closely over the next couple slides um
this does not include any of our normal
tissue our autoimmune tissue or our
metastatic melanoma
um so if we first look um at the tumor
or immune cell populations um you can
see that there are
two types of tumor cells or tumor
populations that exist
those that are highly infiltrated and
those that are not
um we find that lung um and renal tend
to be very highly immune infiltrated
when we have um
analyzed them versus something like
breast colorectal ovarian
which have more of a tumor
representation when we analyze them by
flow
uh c4 and cda t-cells tend to be uh very
standard and actually the averages come
out to be pretty equivalent across all
the tumor types
um except for uh prostate cancer which
instantaneous has a
high percentage of cd8 t cells within
the immune cell fraction
um this was was a little surprising to
us however we went to the literature
there was studies that have confirmed
both by flow and by ihc
a high proportion of cd8t cells within
prostate cancer
as i mentioned previously nk cells are
very very rare um when we do see them it
primarily is within kidney
ovarian or or liver cancer
b cells tend to be restricted mostly to
gastric colorectal cancer
although there are some unique patients
within other indications that have high
percentages of nk cells and b
cells finally for the
the myeloid compartment mostly
myeloid cells are present within brain
cancer and ovarian cancer
um brain this this makes some sense with
the high component of myeloid cells
that's normally present
on within the brain tissue um again this
does vary on a patient by patient
um level granulocytes are by far the
rarest of the myeloid subtypes um and
these happen to also be the only subtype
that we found to be sensitive to the
free stall
um as i mentioned these are averages so
if you look at something like
lung cancer here which upon first look
at this heat map would seem to be all
immune cells with very little tumor
present um this really is an average so
if we look at all of those
uh long dtc's that we've currently
analyzed
you do see that we do see a spread so
while most of the samples are are highly
immune infiltrated we do have some
samples that do have a high tumor
percentage
and then as far as each of the immune
percentages are concerned there are some
that are high for t
cell infiltration or myeloid
infiltration
um and so it really is heterogeneous
among the population so we use this data
mostly
to help with sample selection for
studies that are focused more on t
cells or b cells or monocytes um
but within an indication you will have a
high degree of variability
after the initial characterization of
the dtcs at the cellular subset we
really became interested in looking at
what markers specifically t
cells express and this was really driven
by the um great successes with
checkpoint inhibitor therapies
like ketruta and optivo so there are a
number of molecules on the surface of t
cells that will regulate their activity
both in a positive and negative format
so we first focused on addressing
whether or not we could identify pdl1
and pd1 expression within dtcs um to use
these to
further classify these samples for
downstream analysis
uh to do this we used the um companion
diagnostic for
key true to opdiva which is pdl1
expression by ihc
so in this case we're looking at two
lung cancer and one kidney cancer
patient sample
that we're stained with pdl one um by hc
and identified a sample that was
classified by our pathologist to be a
hundred percent
pdl one express scene have no expression
of pl1 or in the case of the renal
um somewhere in between we then looked
at
matched dtcs so these are samples that
were generated from the same patients as
these ffpe blocks
and when we looked at the tumor cell
fractions within these dissociated tumor
cells
we found a very high degree of
correlation with the
ffp ihc data in that we saw almost
complete expression of pdl1 on the tumor
cells for the sample that 100
no expression on the sample that had
zero percent and a shoulder of
expression on the renal sample that when
gated on was roughly
20 to 30 percent and over all the
samples we've done
we see a high degree of correlation
between the percentage of pdl-1 positive
cells by ihc
compared to the percentage of pdl-1
positive cells by flow
on the nice thing about flow and the
advantage of flow is that
it has multiple markers so we can now
get a little more granular as to what
other cell types within the tumor micro
environment
might express pdl-1 um in this case we
looked at the myeloid compartment as
defined by cd-11b
expression or t-cells by cd3 expression
and found that there was um evidence of
pl1 expression in both of these subsets
although it was very low on t
cells um at this point we've done about
60 samples across the six
indications that currently receive
checkpoint inhibitor therapy in the
clinic
and we found that pretty much for every
indication there are some patients that
will display
uh pdl1 positivity on the tumor cell
fraction
across the board there was some evidence
of pl1 expression on cd11b cells in all
cases except interestingly enough for
renal
um and that wasn't due to a loss or a
deficiency of myeloid cells in that
indication that traditionally does have
a lot of myeloid cells and we've
analyzed it
and finally cd3 cells had very low
expression or very few cells expressing
pdl-1
but they were present in all the
indications we looked at
conversely if we looked at the pd1
receptor
on this case on the immune cell subsets
we saw that most of the cd4 and tat
cells
within the tumor seem to have high
expression of pd1 again this was across
the board in all of the six
indications that we looked at it was
usually greater than 50
um or higher we did look at the other
immune cell subsets within the tumor
including b cells and nk cells for the
most part these cell types were mostly
deficient for pdl-1 expression or pd1
expression excuse me
although there were some um indications
particularly colorectal cancer where
there was evidence of pd1 expression
on b cells and nk cells and again this
was um
confirmed by several studies that have
been published within the academic
literature
so while pd1 and pdl1 served as a grace
case study
um and a known receptor ligand pair um
within the tumor microenvironment we
wanted to take a little more unbiased
look at some of the other receptor
ligand pairs
um that could be present within the
tumor so to
um do this we generated a 14 color flow
cytometry panel
for evaluating these receptor ligand
pairs uh so again this panel first
states out any dead cells by
dappy um any red cells using gly a
we then use the same fcam by cd45
um plot to identify tumor and all immune
cells
this time when we get on the immune
cells however
we first get um on the myeloid cells
that c11 b positive versus the t
cells as cd3 positive cd3 positive t
cells are
further defined by c4 or cd8 into the
cd4 or cd8
compartments the myeloid cells are then
characterized by cd14
and hladr um such that the cd14 positive
cells will be most of those monocytic
cells that are present within the tumor
the cd14 negative cells are generally
always those cell those granulocytic
cells that also expressed cd15
hladr was added so that we could
identify potential
myeloid derived suppressor cells that
might be present within the tumor
and then finally the cdb negative cd3
negative subset
was uh staying for cb19 to identify b
cells um this provides a nice internal
negative control as most of these t-cell
receptors
are not expressed on the b-cell subset
so provides us a nice control
um when we're looking at expression
levels by doing this panel we have three
channels left open
um we used pe apc and the pe size 7
channels as they have the best signals
and that allows us to look a little more
in depth at new
or potentially novel um co-stimulatory
and co-inhibitory molecules that might
be expressed in the tumor
so um again there are a lot of molecules
that
can modulate t cell receptor function um
to do this
by flow would obviously take quite a lot
of time and quite a lot of optimization
so to help us
further um define what cells or what
receptors we'd like to look at we
performed bulk rna-seq
on eight different dtc samples across
four different indications so this heat
map
shows the expression levels of all those
co-simulatory co-inhibitory ligands
and receptors within these eight tumors
the bottom four genes are a t-cell
signature
um which is used to define the cold
tumors which are displayed on the left
versus hot tumors which are displayed on
the right
so if we look first at pe one pdl one
pdl two
um we see at the rna level these are all
expressed um which
is um confirms our flow cytometry data
um interestingly pdl2 is very lowly
expressed although we did
define some expression levels which was
pretty unique
we did look at some of the
co-stimulatory molecules in general
we found the receptors to be expressed
but not the ligands
we did confirm this by flow as well i'm
not going to go through that data today
instead i'm going to focus today on the
other co-inhibitory molecules that were
expressed within the tumor
we saw that there was expression of lag
three tidget vista
and tim3 and in contrast to the
co-stimulatory molecules the ligands for
these co-inhibitory molecules
we did find to be expressed and usually
at fairly high levels
at the rna level so an example of what
this data now looks like is we can
actually analyze
these receptor ligand pairs by flow um
we're showing the data here as a tisny
plot so that we can
remove the bias of pre-dating any cell
type and looking at its expression
pattern
so in this case we're looking at a lung
cancer sample that is very immune
infiltrated
the tumor cells are represented in the
mauve or brownish color in the top
versus the immune cell subsets which are
primarily the t
cells cd4 and cd8 a large b cell
compartment as well as a myeloid
compartment
now when we look at digit expression we
see that the digit expression is
primarily restricted to the t
cell compartment although there is a
small subset of cells in the middle that
does stay positive for tidget based on
other studies we believe these to be nk
cells
conversely the ligand four digit pvr l2
is restricted almost exclusively to the
tumor cells
the myeloid compartment as well as a
compartment of cells that we
have largely believed to be fibroblasts
and enzyal cells
we did look for pvr expression we found
it to be
more lowly expressed than pvr l2 and to
be highly patient dependent some
patients did express
pvr others did not um so we focused
mostly on pbrl2 when we did these
studies
now all of these studies have focused on
primarily using the entire tumor
for flow cytometry analysis but these
single cell suspensions
do work very well for any sort of
downstream magnetic isolation
we've done both t cells uh and tumor
cells
i'm gonna go through the tumor cell data
briefly so
we have used miltenny's tumor cell
enrichment kit
um the beauty of this kit is that it
doesn't predispose any expression of any
molecule on the tumor instead it binds
to everything that should not be tumor
within the tumor microenvironment
including red cells
immune cells fibroblasts and endothelial
cells and basically everything that's
not selected
would therefore be tumor cells so in
this case this is so in an example from
an ovarian cancer cell sample
um again see looking at cd45 by epcam
expression
um you can see that there's about a
forty percent representation of both
populations
as we put it through on this negative
selection process
it's greater than 95 percent have cam
positive which is again the marker that
we've been using to bind tumor cells
although we don't have it doesn't
preclude um samples that don't express
afghan from going through this process
and we have done this with melanoma
and it does work quite well um at this
point we've we've performed this tumor
cell isolations
on over 100 unique samples on almost 10
different indications
um in all cases we do achieve greater
than on 90
afghan positive cells following the
enrichment with a very high viability
um and this goes down into something um
like lung which is notoriously very
immune infiltrated we still can get
greater than 95 percent viability
on these tumor cell enrichments so this
provides us a way to do any sort of
magnetic pre-enrichment prior to going
into
more downstream flow any sort of cell
culture or downstream genomics studies
the final point that we want to talk
about today is
single cell genomic characterization of
dissociative tissues
um so recently we brought in the 10x
genomics platform
um and have been using that to
characterize dissociated tissues
um at the rna level so this workflow is
very similar to our flow workflow for
characterizing dtcs the difference here
is that we do this on both fresh and
frozen samples and all of our samples go
through a
qc check prior to being loaded into the
10x chromium platform
given the expense and the highly
technical nature of single-cell
technologies
we want to make sure that all samples
are of the best quality
and best represent the needs of the
downstream projects
so these inclusion exclusion criteria
can include
um different tumor percentages that are
required for the study
different cd4 cd8t cell ratios and so
everything goes through a qc check
on the maxwell platform prior to being
selected into the study
um if it is selected in this study um
it'll either be directly loaded into the
10x box or go through either a magnetic
or some sort of faxed-based cell sorting
on prior to loading four different
subsets
an example of some of the projects that
we have currently running or have
completed using um associated tissues
includes a large scale study on mutation
characterized colorectal cancer
samples um these were characterized for
k rats n ras
vraf mutations as well as msi status
all of these samples were purified and
the entire tumor microenvironment was
loaded and analyzed by single cell
rna-seq
additionally we have been focusing on
head and neck cancer samples
specifically from the oral cavity
and performing both single cell rna-seq
as well as tsa
tcr and bcr repertoire analysis
we've also been sorting cd three
positive t
cells from multiple indications mostly
long renal and colorectal
these t cells have been um further
profiled for
single cell t cell receptor as well as
site seek
and finally we've been subdividing cda t
cells specifically from renal cell
samples
to perform single cell rna-seq and
t-cell receptor analysis
um so i'm going to go through some data
generated from the colorectal cancer
samples
as well as some of the t cell receptor
cell
data as an example of what this data
looks like
so again using disney plots this is an
example of a single colorectal cancer
dtc sample
in this case we annotated each
population based on the expression of
transcripts for each cell type
um so the top populations are t cell
populations either cd4 or cd8
as this is rna we were able to identify
the t-reg population
by fox p3 expression we were further
able to identify
two b-cell populations um these were
identified by the expression of cd79-a
but interestingly one of them did have
markers
consistent with plasma cells so identify
both a plasma cell and non-plasma cell b
cell fraction the tumor cells are
represented by the brown fraction in the
middle
and then the myeloid cells are the
smaller fraction represented by the pink
now while these disney plots give you
the nice
uh cell subsets within the tumor because
this is single cell rna data we now have
roughly a thousand different transcripts
that we can look at
and see where those transcripts fall
within each of these
annotated populations so one example
is a lytic enzyme such as granzyme b
as expected this is primarily um
restricted to the cd8 compartment
we've looked at all the other grand
zones as well as perforin and again
these are restricted
almost entirely to the cd8t cells nice
proof of concept that these
single cell rna seq dataset is
performing as we would expect
so if we again look at those
co-stimulatory co-inhibitory molecules
particularly pd1 and the tidget family
members
um we can see that this does correlate
great with the flow cytometry data that
we previously generated so pd1 is
primarily expressed by the t cell
compartment
um cd8 t cells as well as the t rags
although the cd4 t cells in this
specific c
uh crc sample have less expression of
pd1 um it is not expressed by the b
cells the myeloid cells
or the tumor cell fraction
so conversely when we look at pdl-1
expression
within this colorectal cancer tumor we
can see that it's largely restricted to
the myeloid compartment
and interestingly enough the key
regulatory compartment
however in this case this the crc tumor
is negative
on the tumor cells for pdl one
expression
now we've looked for pdl2 expression by
flow it's been hard to detect but like
the rna level we
can see that it is expressed um it's not
expressed as
as many cells as pdl one um but it is
expressed by a few
uh t regulatory cells as one as well as
some of the myeloid cells
within this tumor tidget on the other
hand
is expressed much more highly and much
more broadly
than pd1 is in in this specific
colorectal cancer sample
and it's expressed pretty much across
the entire t cell compartment
again it's restricted to that
compartment doesn't seem to be expressed
by any of the other
immune or tumor cell subsets
in this case we can ex define expression
of pvr
uh again it's not to nearly the extent
of pbr
l2 but it is expressed by a few of the
tumor cells as well as some of the
myeloid cells
but the main ligand expressed four digit
is pvr l2 again restricted almost to the
entirely to the myeloid compartment
as well as to part of the tumor
compartment so
this data set really allows you to look
at all
of the cosimulatory co-inhibitory
molecules rather than being restricted
just just a few
on these technology then can be used to
either do bar-coded antibodies in sight
seek
or back to flow cytometry to have
orthogonal assays to really evaluate
this at the protein level
finally um looking at single-cell tcr
repertoire data
looking at c sorted cda t cells from a
renal tumor
uh we do see a high degree of clonality
uh we've seen this actually in all of
the cd8 cells that we've sorted
um such that um oftentimes it's 10 or
greater of the cdi t cells have a single
clonotype
um this is really interesting and really
great for those
folks who are interested in t-cell
repertoire analysis of t-cell therapies
as it allows for the identification of
potentially immune reactive
or tumor reactive t cells
so throughout this talk um i hope we've
been able to uh
discuss how we use um the penny
platforms to phenotype our donors
um from our africaphoresis clinic for
downstream isolations
and potential use in cell therapy
manufacturing
how we use again the the mil penny
platform to characterize
our dtcs um at a high degree
for both the use of sample selection as
well as for identification of new and
novel targets
and then finally how these dtc's can be
used um in single cell
rna-seq and and other single-cell
technologies
uh to again identify on apple biomarkers
so that'll take any questions um and we
can always be reached at either our
website
dls.com or through contacting us at
info dls.com thank you
thank you dr fall for your informative
presentation we'll now start the q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
okay let's go ahead and get started our
first question
is how long does it take to get a donor
collected
and luca packs shipped once we submit a
request
so for donors where there's no inclusion
exclusion criteria
it's usually about 10 to 15 business
days um we're generally
scheduled about two weeks in advance um
for any collection
if there is inclusion exclusion criteria
it can take a little bit longer for us
to identify
the correct owner but generally the two
to three week turnaround
is what we're currently looking at
great thank you okay let's see do you
see rare cell types in your leukopaks
we do so we we have identified the
dendritic cell subsets
um primarily we focused on plasmacytoid
dendritic cells although the myeloid
dendritic cells are also present
uh we do also see cd34 positive stem
cells
in these leukopaks they tend to vary on
more than the
more popular or more abundant t cell b
cell subsets
um but they are present within in the
local packs
how do you evaluate new or unknown
targets of
interest that is a great question and
that's probably the question that we get
the most
uh when we talk about dissociative tumor
cells so
any new or unknown targets um since our
process is mechanical and enzymatic
what we do is we'll do a mock
dissociation either on pbmcs or a cell
line where we know that the marker is
expressed
those cells then go through the
dissociation and are compared against
undissociated cells to see if there's
any sensitivity on to the receptor
or to the um enzymatic mixture if there
is we do have the option to change the
dissociation protocol
it tends to negatively impact viability
but it does
overall retain expression of all of the
receptors
that we've looked at so far
thank you dr fall we have time for a
couple more questions here
your next question have you attempted
have you ever attempted to culture
dtcs we have so we've had good success
culturing dtc's both in
term and long term uh for short term
they work very well for spheroid
cultures
uh we do highly recommend using the
ultra low attachment plates
uh the more traditional tissue culture
coated plates um the cells will try to
attach a lot of times that causes cell
death pretty quickly
um we also know that these dtcs are
amenable to the long-term organoid
cultures
and the semi-solid matrix they do take a
while to
propagate but they do work quite well
for that technology
all right let's go ahead and wrap up
with this last question
have you tried atac seek and what would
the workflow look like
so we are about to uh undertake our
first ataxy project
so the workflow for those projects is a
little different um as it does need
nuclei
isolation prior to going into a taxi uh
what we do in that case is we oftentimes
do a pre-pilot
where we'll actually figure out the
exact right conditions for either the
frozen tissue or the cell
type to get uh accurate and efficient
nuclear isolation
once we figured that out then we'll move
actually on to the atexique part of the
project
uh and that way we don't have to waste
valuable material
optimizing and going directly into
sequencing when it's not needed
thank you again dr fall for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor miltoni biotek
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their questions any questions we
did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye